الذين يثيرون هذه القضية هم
الذين لا يريدون وحدة السلام والوحدة الوطنية
في أفغانستان ،
ويتذرعون بحق المرأة
وحقوق الأقليات في محاولة إلحاق
الضرر بالنظام
الذي نحمده ، ولله الحمد
للمبادئ الدينية
والتقاليد الوطنية.
لا يمكن العثور على الحقوق التي أعطاها الإسلام للمرأة في أي دين أو
أمة ، حيث إن أفغانستان معرضة للخطر بشأن
قضية النساء المتمثلة في عدم تجميد حساباتها
، الأموال المجمدة هي حق الشعب
وليس لها أي علاقة
بالحكومة والسياسة
من حق الأمة الأمة الفقيرة
بأموال مجمدة لا يمكنهم جعلنا
نسخها وإحضار ثقافتهم هنا ،
فهذا يتعارض مع
معتقداتنا وتقاليدنا ، فهذه هي
القضية الكبيرة القادمة للشعب الأفغاني
هل المال يأتي أم لا
في المستقبل ،
لن نتخلى عن
حقوق
شعبنا ، سنبذل قصارى جهدنا من أجل
حق شعبنا بنفس الطريقة التي فعلناها
في العشرين عامًا الماضية ،
وهذا هو حق  الناس ، هذا
ليس حق بايدن أو حق
حكومة الولايات المتحدة
حتى يتمكنوا من الاستيلاء عليه لتجميده
كم من الوقت لديك قبل أن يبدأ الاقتصاد
في الأذى حقًا
إذا كان العالم يعتقد أنه يمكنهم ممارسة
الكثير من الضغط علينا  من خلال هذا
الأمر
أننا سنقبل ما يريدون منا
أن نقبله أثناء الحرب ، فهذا اعتقاد خاطئ جدًا
عنهم ليس في أيدي بايدن
أوروبا روسيا أو الصين
الحمد لله ، نحن لا نخاف من
هذه المشقة ، فهذه هي علاقتنا.
الله سبحانه وتعالى
متى ستعتبر الحرب مع
أمريكا قد انتهت
وانتهت سياسة الإمارة الإسلامية هي
أننا نريد علاقات دبلوماسية إيجابية
مع العالم بأسره
بما في ذلك الولايات المتحدة
الآن الأمر متروك لهم
ولكن
الآن قضية تجميد الأموال وقضايا أخرى
هذه حرب هذه هي كسر
العلاقات ، الإمارة الإسلامية تريد
علاقات إيجابية مع كل
يوم أمس قدمنا دعوة إلى ال
مم المتحدة أيضا ال
يد سهيل شاهين وه
ا يعني  نحن جاهزون لكل
علاقة إيجابية تدعم السلام
والأمن ولا تتعارض
مع مبادئنا الدينية والعقيدة والتقاليد الوطنية ،
ما مدى السرعة التي تحتاجها إلى هذا
الاعتراف الدولي
بحكومة طالبان أسابيع شهور إلى متى كادونا
إذا كان العالم يريد السلام و
يمكن تحقيق الأمن في يوم واحد ،
فهو مفيد لهم ومفيد
لنا أيضًا إذا كانوا لا يريدون السلام
والأمن ويريدون أن يواجه الناس هنا
المصاعب والمشاكل ،
فمن المؤكد أن الأمر قد يستغرق وقتًا
ولكن
هذا في أفضل الأحوال  مصلحة الجميع
في أن تتحقق بشكل عاجل
لأخيك مكافأة قدرها 10 ملايين دولار على
رأسه
ماذا ستفعل حيال
أن الإمارة الإسلامية لديها اتفاق
مع الأمريكيين في الدوحة نحن جزء من
تلك الاتفاقية القائمة السوداء
التي تلتزم بها  هناك أنه
سيتم القضاء عليه ، يجب أن نفي
بهذا الالتزام حتى يخلف الأمريكيون
الوعد بسحب المكافأة
منك  رئيس الأخ
في اتفاقية الدوحة ، كان هناك قسمان
أحدهما هو القائمة السوداء
الدولية والآخر هو
القائمة السوداء لمكافأة الولايات المتحدة ، والآخر الذي قدمه مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الأمريكي
بشأن هاتين القائمتين
، وهل ستسمح للولايات
المتحدة بضربات الطائرات بدون طيار  داخل أفغانستان
ضد تنظيم الدولة الإسلامية أو ضد القاعدة ،
لا نحتاج إلى مساعدة أحد في هذا
الأمر ، فمن واجب حكومتنا
ألا نمنح هذا الإذن أبدًا
للولايات المتحدة للحضور إلى هنا والقيام
بذلك بمحض إرادتها ، فنحن أنفسنا
كافون من أجل  هذه كحكومة مستقلة
، هل ستعمل مع الولايات المتحدة
على قضايا مكافحة الإرهاب ،
وقد تم تحديد هذه المبادئ في
اتفاقية الدوحة
، ولم تُمنح الولايات المتحدة
الإذن بالحضور إلى هنا للقيام بهذا
العمل ، ويمكنها التوصل إلى تفاهم مع
إسلام إسلامي.  فيما يتعلق ببعض القضايا
في ضوء مبادئها